et
m
cinq élèves cinq années de joie et de
peine 5 façon de grandir de s'accrocher
à l'école et à la vie 5 réactions à la
fin avortée de leurs études secondaires
c'est la période la plus importante pour
nous on avait nos fans au dernier
concert j'ai l'impression de pouvoir
boucler la boucle comme andy dès qu'il
manque quelque chose qui manquait de
vivre des moments très durs parce que
j'ai l'impression que c'est comme
vraiment quelque chose qui arrive une
fois dans une vie c'est elle mais je le
redis rebuy j'avais même la colère je me
disais bon est encore oublié les écoles
secondaires ne vont pas réouvrir à 20 la
fin du mode où j'étais assise sur le 10
juin 10 salon et j'ai complètement fondu
en larmes j'ai pleuré
une semaine plus tard lorient italie
vidé son casier le coeur en miettes
je n'aurais jamais pensé que ma dernière
journée offre secondaire en tant
qu'élève se seraient déroulés comme ça
elle publie ensuite ce texte qui fait
boule de neige sur les réseaux sociaux
je m'attendais à voir des gens pleurer
des gens rire des gens se serrer dans
leurs bras
à la place je vais encore vide vite
d'élèves vite de profs m'évite de vie
aussi
j'ai vraiment peur que ce soit sur mon
dernier mon dernier souvenir en fait
demain de ma vie au secondaire le ca me
fait ça me fait pas rire ça me fait mal
lorient n'a écrit et son directeur pour
réclamer une cérémonie sur le grand
terrain de football de l'école c'est ce
que c'est des moments qui sont
difficiles ou une espèce de perte de
contrôle aussi donc c'est clairement pas
me caresser ce que ça nous touche
beaucoup quand on reçoit des lettres
comme celle là donc on est sensible le
directeur veut souligner ce rite de
passage important mais sa marge de
manoeuvre est mince
pour l'instant les écoles publiques se
font dire que les cérémonies de remise
de diplômes ne sont pas possibles les
collèges privés semblent avoir plus de
possibilités
allô allô c'est un rituel de passage
puis on va être là pour vous et on vous
réserve un paquet surprise dans les
prochaines semaines
parce que on s'est attaché à vous la
directrice de l'institut ker anna promet
même une cérémonie sur place quatre de
ses élèves ont lancé une pétition
réclamant au ministre de l'éducation
une dernière journée à l'école près de
vingt mille jeunes québécois l'ont signé
pour nous c'est vraiment la journée qu
on parlais tantôt avec l'album la remise
d'albums dessous puis on pense que c'est
passé avec les démesures center on pense
qu'on est assez mature pour faire seule
c'est on est quand même celle de cette
année on est capable de respecter tout
au plus des deuils toutes ces dernières
fois qu'ils ne vivront pas certains
jeunes ont une épée de damoclès
au-dessus de la tête
florence n'était pas certaine que ses
notes en français lui permettra
d'obtenir son diplôme mais elle
travaille fort depuis deux mois
ils sont enseignants puis dit maintenant
que ça devrait aller et je me considère
chanceuse moins chanceuse d'avoir eu
accès à l'école privée d'avoir un très
très bon encadrement pour finir mon
secondaire
moi j'ai l'impression après que les
élèves du privé qui se sont vraiment
investis à 100% voire bosse et j'ai prêt
à 100% sur mettons du public qui ont eu
m en moins travaux afin moins
d'encadrement et marveaux ses jappements
est un peu déstabilisé je lacombe qui
fréquentent une école publique à
montréal fait le même constat
son petit frère qui est au privé fait
l'école à distance depuis la deuxième
semaine du confinement lui n'a rien eu à
faire pendant deux mois mois pouvoir mes
amis j'ai fait comme j'ai pas céder
avant midi a pleuré dans ma chambre
parce que cherche quoi faire déprimer
correctement aujourd'hui je le crains
d'échouer en français je me disais moi
au début de l'année c'est toujours ce
que je fais j'embarque la balle à
l'école mais je me reprends 3ème étape
puis le croire aussi à l'arbre plus des
cages le site belge fait le pied je
recommence motionnaire scène qu'est ce
qu'on te dit exactement que tu avais
besoin de faire pour être sûr de passer
d'assister à tous les courbes et de
faire les devoirs
[Musique]
julien la belle est en concentration
musique dans une école publique
les jeunes dans ces programmes d'arrêt
de sport études font aussi le 2d match
de fin de saison des spectacles et des
concerts de fin d'année la musique au
niveau non secondes à sa prime d'un
plongeur ses lanières de s'échapper une
manière de définir aussi parce qu'on est
un groupe on on se forme une gagne
fillon on pratiquer ensemble montre et
puis on a du fun qui s'est en fait qui
que françois que l'émotion est encore
plus importante pour nous passions la
musique on propulse la ville de samson
je vais loin de toi que je les fais
allongé mes cheveux la mère de julien
enseigne la musique à l'école de sa
fille elle fait partie de l'équipe qui
prépare des surprises aux finissants je
trouve que c'est c'est des moments hyper
important elle
commençons émotivement puis je pense
qu'ils ont besoin ils ont besoin
profondément de de vivre tous ces
moments là julia et d'autres élèves de
5e secondaire ont fait cette vidéo pour
remercier leurs enseignants quand on lui
demande son plus beau souvenir de ses
années au secondaire
la jeune violoncelliste répond
spontanément caroline le mais c'est
l'incroyable professeur de musique ends
appris tard au juste la musique mais
être de la vie en général une coach de
vie comme on prend cinq élèves cinq
histoires différentes tout avec la même
fin abrupte aujourd'hui tous partagent
le même rêve se revoir une dernière fois
à l'école qui les a vu grandir pendant
cinq ans
[Musique]